تنضم إلينا جيرمانا كراتشي الآن في
منطقة دارنا المتضررة بشدة، شكرًا لك جامانا
لوجودك هناك، لقد غطيت الكثير من
المآسي. قارن هذا بمناطق الحرب
تلك [
موسيقى] كما
تعلم يا خشخاش، كان فريقنا
يناقش هذا للتو، لقد قمنا جميعًا بتغطية الحروب والكوارث
الطبيعية  من قبل ولكن لم
ير أي منا شيئًا كهذا، أعني أننا
قدنا السيارة إلى درنة في وقت متأخر من الليلة الماضية،
حتى أثناء الليل في الظلام، لا يزال
بإمكانك رؤية الدمار، والآن
خلال النهار، يعد هذا مجرد
دمار تام تمامًا، ويبدو الأمر كذلك حقًا
أنت تسير في منطقة حرب وكأن
قنابل ضخمة قد انفجرت هنا، وهذا ما
سيخبرك به الناس هنا، كما تعلم أن
لديك العديد من المدن على طول
الساحل الليبي التي تأثرت بالعاصفة
دانيال بسبب الفيضانات خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
ولكن لا شيء  هكذا ما يصفه الناس
هنا بهذه الكارثة ما
حدث في درنة طبعا كما تعلم
هو هذين السدين اللذين انفجرا
ولديك مياه الفيضانات التي اجتاحت
المدينة وجرفت مباني بأكملها أحياء
أه منازل البنية التحتية
عائلات وجلبت كل شيء  هنا إلى
البحر إلى البحر الأبيض المتوسط، أعني أنه من
الصعب جدًا علينا
تحريك الكاميرا بسبب
مشكلات الاتصال أو
انقطاع الاتصالات في
المدن، لذا فإن اتصالنا ليس
مستقرًا للغاية ولكن بالنظر إلى خشخاش البحر
ما نراه هنا هو حياة الناس
هناك، ترى المنازل، ترى إطارات الأبواب، النوافذ،
الأثاث، الملابس، السيارات،
كل شيء، وما زالوا
يبحثون الآن عن الجثث التي لا
تزال تجرفها الأمواج إلى الشاطئ
بعد ستة أيام من وقوع هذه المأساة
الآن المسؤولون الليبيون  يقولون إن حوالي
5000 شخص قتلوا، ولا
يزال هناك 10000 شخص في عداد المفقودين، ويقول
المسؤولون الذين تحدثنا إليهم
إنهم لا يتوقعون العثور على المزيد من
الناجين في الوقت الحالي وما لدينا
هنا حيث نحن جميعًا  هؤلاء
المتطوعون من مختلف أنحاء
البلاد الذين يعملون ويحاولون
المساعدة في جهود التعافي هذه وهي
مهمة صعبة، ويخبروننا
أنهم غير مجهزين للتعامل مع
شيء مثل هذا، وليس لديهم
الوسائل  والقدرة على القيام بهذا
الشاب الذي كنت أتحدث معه منذ
وقت قصير فقط واصفًا كيف كان الناس
يربطون الحبال بأنفسهم
ويمسكون بعضهم البعض بينما كانوا يغوصون
في البحر ويبدأون في إخراج
جسد تلو الآخر هذا الشاب
علمني وفي أحد الأيام قام بسحب 40
جثة آه بنفسه
والآن المتطوعون هنا
يقولون انظروا إنهم بحاجة إلى معدات ثقيلة،
لديك سيارات عالقة هناك
ولا يعرفون عدد الأشخاص الذين
ما زالوا هناك  هناك يشعرون بالقلق من أن
هناك أشخاصًا ما زالوا جثثًا
بالطبع في هذه السيارات ويريدون
الدعم ويريدون المساعدة ويريدون
معدات ثقيلة ويريدون غواصين ويريدون
معدات غوص لمحاولة
انتشال أكبر عدد ممكن من الجثث، لقد
حصلوا على بعض الجثث  الدعم الدولي لقد
رأينا بعض المراهقين هنا على
الأرض، كان الأتراك بالفعل على متن
قارب مطاطي منذ فترة قصيرة، وكانت
لديك طائرات هليكوبتر في الهواء، لكن
ليس هناك ما يكفي من الخشخاش للتعامل مع
هذه الكارثة